it's funny because we had like a couple
of presidential candidates you know
interested and they probably saw the
first video of like would you rather
[__] your mom or your dad because that's
a question we ask a lot of the guests so
I'll go into it um
I'm glad you guys asked me that so let
me tell you why it's my dad
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where we have uh all right what's up
guys we're ready we got Gianni out here
today everybody big time enough yeah
it's big
bro I'm so glad to be back I was on the
phone I was on the phone too with with
you oh yeah I was on the phone with John
I was I was trying to negotiate a better
lunch but they could only do a side
Chick-fil-A fry so I was like all right
maybe you're doing Chick-fil-A dude we
should do Chick-fil-A I think I think
you sparked something but I just gone
down here that's all I'll say we're all
sharing a 30 count so what's up man how
you been it's been a while yeah I've
been good his rates went up yeah why'd
you want to come back I know right you
reached out to us and was like no no no
no dude
and like I want to come on JK I saw your
name on the closet but it said Johnny
and I had to ask because I wasn't sure I
was like who's Johnny yet and then Ryan
put your IG in the in the link and I
clicked oh the perfect dick dude yeah
yeah dude last episode you guys made me
talk a lot about my [__] so this one
we're gonna talk about my [__] this
one we're talking about my accent is
your [__] perfect too nah dude that
shit's [__] up wait do you even know
what it looks like
why are you so interested because I
don't know what my [__] looks like
liar you never did a bend over I'm
scared because I'm scared to see what it
looks like but one time I forgot what
we're doing my my son because he was
like oh my butthole's itchy and all the
way she go check it out and I see him
out in front of a mirror butt naked
looking like that that's how you do it
and it was the funniest thing I've ever
seen and through the reflection of the
mirror I was like wait I've seen your
butthole even before I've seen mine yeah
I don't know I still don't but I feel
like that's probably you've never seen
your butthole it didn't have hair when I
was four yeah that's actually true
that's actually a good time when you
start getting hair on that when you see
the paintbrush on the toilet paper so
you've only seen kids buttholes but I
feel like everyone's parent everyone's
parent has probably seen all of them you
know like my dad's probably seen the
inside of my [__] you know what I
mean an inside no uh just
so what's the next segment
specifically about [__] you wanted
to bring it no no but you know what
you're no no right do you know how come
you're judging me so hard have I seen my
[__] as a girl man yes I have what
does it look like it looks like an
[__] and then there's like paint
brushes around it is it attractive
I wouldn't say it's attractive no yeah
no I don't have one of those like damn
that's an [__] people shouldn't be
looking at buttholes though I don't
think get a hobby you know I mean it's
like do something better with your time
that's good that means you're busy that
means you're you know your time as well
maintained yeah so from going on Power
and then coming out
talk about butthole let's talk about is
it very liberating to be here so you
could say whatever the hell you want
um honestly you wanna know what the good
thing about uh Stars specifically
actually not Stars maybe our show
there's kind of like not any rules
because 50 Cent is our executive
producer oh that's tight and this dude
goes on Instagram and says wild [__] so
like some cyber bullies people dude no
he doesn't but he does it in the right
way he doesn't bully anyone he's just
50. no but like I'm not gonna tell him
anything I think it's okay I think it's
fun I think I do like whatever like
imagine if I said like if I said
something and they're like whoa and I'm
like what the [__]
he runs it you're like you don't need to
get out of here I feel like we have a
lot of leeway to kind of be ourselves
which I love but I think now that
because I said stars but I was like
Outlet the guy's an Outlander aren't
like doing wild [__] you're not talking
about their asses right right you're not
outlandish right yeah I like that yeah
men in kills all right you know what I'm
saying you said Happy Birthday to
someone that's pretty nice of him the 50
Cent yeah that's what I was supposed
that's my co-star that's
he's pretty nice to people I remember
one of those I literally was just with
him three days ago I went to his concert
in Chicago really yeah brought me out on
stage what was that like do you feel
like I heard your music already like you
get bored like you're like you should
definitely say that what what you're
like I heard your music already too much
like you know when you get too
comfortable with someone and then after
a while you're like I want to go to your
show bro no bro I seen him I have seen
him live literally maybe 50 times his
full it it's better every time yeah dude
every time he has a show he brings us
dude he brought me out on stage in
Prague he brought me out on stage like
he brings me like if I go to a show
because he does Big Rich Town which is
our theme song yeah if he does it and
I'm at a show he just brings me he
brought me on stage four nights ago what
do you do start dancing no he just says
anyone watch power and everyone goes
crazy and then they say we got some
special guests from the show and they'll
bring me out and the whole place goes
nah dude it's insane
that's tight man so back to my [__]
so
maybe you could bring him here one day
we can ask him about his butthole um I I
just World Tour but um if he does make
time for JK news I will definitely bring
him here put a name out there or at
least ask him if he knows what it looks
like
do you know what
you know what and your [__] looks
like
it's funny because we had like a couple
of presidential candidates you know
interested and they probably saw the
first video of like would you rather
[__] your mom or your dad because that's
a question we ask a lot of the guests
and they're like maybe not I don't know
so I'll go into it um
so let me tell you why it's my Dad wait
you read presidents of Candace that want
to come on here they did it no we
weren't talking with their team yeah and
then we assume they do their research
and they watch the video and then they
saw they saw a picture of Nick Dunn like
this and they're like nah we're good
special people on their show
that's all I'm saying dude uh but yeah
we how many presidential candidates do
you think we had like three that's
that's a good number we got one in the
works it might happen I don't know we
got more than the view I'm gonna keep my
hopes not that high yeah keep it as low
as possible honestly if we had a
presidential candidate it's like what
would we talk to him about about his
campaign I would ask him
[Laughter]
they're like let's wrap this up if we
had a presidential candidate on here
he's probably losing points in the polls
right after the episode no I think
people will like him even more but these
guys are real yeah dude that's honestly
that's the issues like Trump was like
too [__] like he was too like wild
instead like crazy like racist [__] here
and there but like people [__] with
him because he was real so imagine if
someone who was like somewhat
level-headed came and started doing [__]
like Bobby Lee's podcast JK news Theo's
pocket people be like dude I [__] with
this guy just you just can't like hum
toilet paper at like Mexican people you
know what I mean it's like just relax on
that end my guy you know what I mean
yeah then what's his face okay
dude I went to his house last year rfk's
house yeah and where Malibu or uh should
I I don't know if I should say well
um
yeah I went to like a Christmas party
there last year it was while it was like
Bill Burr did he know he was running no
he knows a lot of comics because his
wife oh yeah she's a Curb Your
Enthusiasm yeah oh wait wait wait he's
running for president yeah dude I don't
know anything dude unless it's unless
those are Christmas parties but has no
idea who the guys he's running for
president
crazy dude you didn't know that no I
just knew what Larry David was there I
was like cool
um and then I left yeah and then I went
home you know Larry David hooked him up
with the with his wife now did he or
Cheryl hi that's pretty cool do you
think he would [__] his mom or his dad
to RFK yeah since you know him yeah
since you go to his Christmas party I'm
not gonna answer for him because because
he might have it we'll let him out yeah
do you think I just took away his
chances of coming on the show by asking
that well I'm just assuming he's going
to see this episode you're Assuming he's
gonna he's not gonna see this episode
you don't think he subscribed already I
watched him on the Bobby Lee podcast and
I made him really really like him really
yeah because like he's such a real dude
and a lot of times like um because we
have friends that are in politics not at
that high level but if you go on a
touchy subject they'll just like pretend
like they didn't even hear that yeah
they're politicians yeah yeah but with
him like uh Bobby and kalila they're
talking about like sex in their
relationship
and then uh Bobby was like well it's
like uh it's a sex is a small part of
the relationship and then like RFK was
like a small part and then his wife was
like because in ours sex is a big part
dude just to [__] around like that he's
like he's like big yeah yeah
yo did you see the first five minutes
though his face was like he's like like
this and his mouth was wide open because
Bobby was doing his like thing where
he's like doing his intro and he starts
going into songs
and then he was like the [__] probably
why'd I say yes Bobby's crazy if you
don't know him yeah I'm curious if he
did know him or his publicist just set
that up like yeah I think I think they
just set it up and she's probably like
the whole time just trying to gather
what the [__] is going on it's so funny
dude so so did has the rider strike and
all that messed stuff up for you guys or
the shoots and all that weirdly enough I
um we wrapped at midnight
um when the actors struck so like when
when the writers Were Striking we still
were filming because all of our scripts
were done and we had to go to work so
like because we're under contract we had
to go to work but the writer strike
happened at midnight or uh we wrapped at
midnight and then the actor strike
happened at 3am wow uh so we finished
our last day so you're just like now I
could go protest but not have any
feelings of I didn't finish my work yeah
the actors hadn't hadn't gone on strike
so we were still working so then right
when the actors went on strike we had
finished so you got lucky yeah so we we
worked right up until the thing I mean I
got a couple movies lined up that I
can't do but you know [__] it where is
the money I just can't relax I've had
too much prime dude I'm like [__]
does it stress you out knowing there's
the projects that you're like oh [__] I
was like counting on that money or I
want more income to come no I don't I'm
not the type of person that that you
know there's a lot of people that go oh
I have this this already lined up that's
my money like until that [__] is in my
account I don't start counting my money
so so that's the way I kind of you have
to in this business because you could
get a whole movie lined up you're like
all these huge actors and then all of a
sudden like you know the person is like
oh I'm gonna go do this other movie and
then the per the funding falls out
because they had him lined up to sell
the movie and now they don't want to
fund it so you know call back like but I
just bought a Lamborghini yeah no I
can't do that
would you think that might be one of the
most stressful like industry
because one strand can pull and the
whole thing that falls seemed like it
was already in concrete is just for sure
well think about like it is the I think
it's the hardest industry in the world
to break into because everyone wants to
do it go up to any person on the street
and say would you want to be in a movie
yes yes go up to any person on the
street because you want to work on this
construction shirt you want to do this
they'd be like [__] no you know what I
mean like so everyone wants to do it if
they could you know what I mean and I'm
not saying it's like better than
anything else I'm just saying like it's
the one profession because I think if
you book the job it's pretty fun and
easy it looks fun as [__] yeah so I
don't know it there there's like a lot
that goes into it but it's very [__]
hard to like once you're in it to also
stay relevant stay working like you
could be on a show look at these people
who are on a show for 10 years and they
never work again
has anyone ever told you you'll never
work in the city again yeah no but I I
want that to happen so then I could just
be like at night like you [__] you
think I'm never gonna work again
like keep me going and you get
motivation yeah yeah that [__] in and
out said I'll never work again he said I
was a bomb isn't that what happened to
Keanu Reeves though like he was like no
movies for 10 years then he's like [__]
it I'll make John Wick by myself and
then Hollywood was like hey we want to
work with you again yeah is that what he
did I think he got blacklisted so no
movies for 10 years so that's why his uh
stunt his stunt man was like the one
I'll let me write in direct because I
know what your capabilities are I'm the
one that's your body double for
everything it's all right perfectly to
your abilities they shot that I think
was Indie funded then it blew the [__]
up and I think not everyone's like well
we need to make two three four five six
seven I did not so according to the
actor Fox Studios decided to put Reeves
name on a blacklist after he refused to
appear in a potential sequel to the 94
Thriller speed during the negotiations
about the sequel Sandra Bullock agreed
to reprise her role but Reeves wasn't
interested so all he said was no one
they blacklisted him
according to him remember they're on a
boat it was [__] crazy I heard that
that kind of stuff happens but you know
I'm not in the industries as a
conspiracy well maybe maybe
contractually in his original speed
thing said like if it was successful you
have to be like a part of the sequel or
something like [__] 40 years ago Dude
I saw that movie that he The Matrix you
know that one yeah the newest one do you
know just the first one I saw it the
other night for the first time literally
it was the first time you've never seen
it you guys have seen it a million times
dude when you when it first came out
this yeah this was [__] crazy in the
theater no they've done it a bunch of
times after I see that in Tick Tock I
know but it started the whole hulky no
but for real though yeah I was being
funny but I did actually just watch The
Matrix for the first time no you you
just watched the first one watch the
fourth one now wow no don't don't ever
watch
first through
three did I even see the third one the
other one's actually kind of fun
especially if you're like high okay
because the third one brings the big war
together yeah the giant [__] machine
one you're like oh I'm gonna smoke meth
and watch the four numbers oh my God
yeah okay what'd you think of the first
one though it was good but like I feel
like you're like right I should have
watched it when it came like you know me
or like a while ago because now I'm like
it was like like [__] one of my first
standing ovations in a movie theater
really it was one of the first movies I
watched again after I watched it you
can't watch the 70s NBA finals and then
go oh these guys are whatever 100 100
that's almost exactly how it feels
LeBron James everyone else sucks but I
can I can respect the you know what I
mean like wow this was 30 however years
ago this is a relic right right right
but now I just I'm excited for Paw
Patrol to come out so I'm just like
that's gonna crush the box office okay
it probably is to be honest PAW Patrol's
pretty what's your version of all like
like what Matrix was to like our
generation like what's your movie that's
like oh this is my [__] favorite like
my favorite movie of all time and it's
not anything like it's the town Ben
Affleck yeah you really like that one
bro that's my favorite time of all time
is that the heist one yeah I grew up
like 30 minutes from there and I spent a
lot of time in Boston so like yeah oh so
he doesn't have any cultural connection
to the Matrix that's why yeah oh a kid
in my uh middle school did wear a trench
coat a lot so
a little creepy dude yeah a little
scared I was like yeah
[Laughter]
Cole's either Italian or Irish kind of
thing going on and then he loves the
movie yeah yeah yeah I still stand by
the fact that Inception is the best
movie of the 2010s I could get on board
with that for sure I could I could see
that that was the first movie I ever uh
bought a ticket watched it and then went
to go buy another and watch the next
showing wow oh back to back during the
[__] spinning thing I was like five
seconds no [__] away all right I did
that for bleed for this it's a Rhode
Island boxing movie
dude yeah that's where you're from
though right yeah from Rhode Island I'm
like it's boxing Rhode Island accents
I'm coming back you know what I mean I
came back for the demo I get it yeah
yeah
take the movie yeah yeah yeah be the
only one in the theater the second time
no it's actually yeah the second time I
was yeah
first time first time half full second
time empty you know what movie did that
to me uh [__] better luck tomorrow no
really well because better let's not I'm
not saying about [__] ticket and
watch it again because it's [__]
tragic but it's because though um out of
those four ages one uh two of them went
to Bonaparte and two of them went to
Sunny Hills High which the high school I
went to you mean the real story or the
actors the real story so it was relevant
to our entire [__] ecosystem every
time I hear better luck tomorrow I
always think it's [__] what's to do
with the dubs and he has the guns John
John Wu oh John Wu I always think it's a
John Woo movie but it's not a job it
would have been way better man
it's the fast furious director the first
guy yeah yeah the student yeah yeah at
Anthony's old high school kind of [__]
well they did it in the garage in Buena
Park and they buried them in the
backyard where I live really close to
that so cool yeah really cool did you
feel like it was an untold story uh you
know what's actually funny when that
movie came out over the weekend like
half the school went to go watch it and
I remember when we came back in the next
uh that Monday we went into class and it
was our math teacher that uh everybody
was kind of the air was just different
and then when she uh walks into class uh
in the first 30 seconds she's like all
right I know you guys want to ask me
about the movie so go ahead because she
had been at that school for like the
last like 15 20 years oh so she knew
about that so she knew about it do you
know the backstory of better luck
tomorrow no so I thought you guys were
talking about Better Call Saul
dude it's a stupid Asian Niche film so
it doesn't even matter to you like have
you seen train to Busan I'm like [__]
I'm sorry guys I didn't know I had to do
a homework before I'm not here it's like
have you ever ate [__] green onion
frog legs
who played Han on Tokyo Drifters on
power so I met him oh really yeah like
tomorrow that that's the movie that that
got him put him on that put him on that
was his first time I put him on
that's disrespectful you didn't even
know that movie and you met him he's a
he's a legend yeah
there's a
yeah yeah you guys like pull back some
like curtain there's like a there's Han
and John Cho dude he's the man I took a
piss next to him and urinal I kind of a
star shot holding my dick he's tall
thought I shouldn't say anything because
I was holding my dick he was also those
first love interest on film oh really
yeah because in the fastest you know
that oh that's right Johnny doesn't
watch any movies apparently dude I don't
think with Asian people in it that's not
true I know there's like an Asian extra
in Matrix I'm like I'm not watching
CeCe that turns it off yeah I'm like
damn it they they swindled us again I've
never watched Beverly Hills Ninja
I've seen the Hulk Hogan ninja movies
yeah there you go dude yeah holy [__]
they got one eye big in the other
I don't even know why that was a
character thing that they asked him to
do
because it was essential yeah he was the
man you're gonna be the wise Kung Fu
Master yeah they needed an Asian Grandpa
to teach three white kids how to fight
that's just Grandpa yeah so the kids are
technically part Asian then they are but
they're that's so funny yeah
which still makes sense I think they
were supposed to be half asian No
Quarter I think because it was the
grandpa on the mom side I think okay
that's all you need to be good at
martial arts you just need a quarter
Asian bro that's it that's why ten
percent that's why I get submitted a lot
I'm all Norwegian so I suck
[Music]
foreign